hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to hey
kids it's Saturday night hey hey hey
your friends are free hey you can't
drive oh but thank God Nickelodeon's got
you covered for every Saturday night
Nickelodeon was kind enough to give us
snick snick was a gathering of some of
Nickelodeon's most popular shows along
with a few new ones that would air every
single Saturday night their symbol with
an orange couch that was so tacky for
any homeowner to take in that they left
it outside now I've already talked about
some of these shows like Ren & Stimpy
Rugrats and Clarissa explains at all but
there were a lot of other shows that
we're going into the mix two shows that
once again he'll pick Logan get its
identity so let's start with one of
mickle Odie's biggest hit punish let's
start with this roundhouse
roundhouse was a sketch show that was
kind of like that improv review scene
that isn't really funny but God knows
they're trying it was pretty much kids
who performed in front of a live
audience
with no real sense very few props and
practically no costumes we were supposed
to imagine all those like imagine that I
have a remote control now imagine that
I'm changing the channel oh wait I don't
that's why we have concrete man get hurt
they won't perform sketches musical
numbers and all sorts of other crap or
trying to somehow convey a message
hi I'm Mac McMurray try saying that
three times real fast like Mary Mary
Mary remember yes eh I can't even say it
and it's my own dieing name remember
those lame self-esteem groups that will
come to your school do some sketches and
actually make you want to return to your
class just imagine that in primetime in
fact some of these sketches actually
seem a little risque for a kids show
like they actually use the word hell a
few times hell man I'll bail and how
about this bit about looking at a girl's
breasts really you're gonna talk about
girl's breasts why can't I get a got it
look me in the eye I've got brains
I've got charm I've got huge
problem John despair cuz it's derringer
pair trying to cross your eyes brought
from blades bag hey four-eyes what do
you say we go get a milkshake and just
talk that's right if only women have
breasts on their eyes then we would pay
attention to them this show would go by
so fast they was actually kind of hard
to tell if what you just watched was
funny or not like Marge this sketch
about a game show up bully
I'll take kidney punches for the heck of
it Oh Indian burns because I can and
purple nurples fucking lead you think
it's all glass
in that case I'll try running like a bat
out of hell for a thousand bill
fancy hi why are we dancing hey what the
hell it's like they ran out of punch
line so they just decided to dance oh no
I have no Segway what should I do
there aren't you full of dance quick
bring in the interpretive dancing minds
to help enough and speaking of songs
every song in the show sounds like that
Christian rock music I can find a friend
everyone's got a mission in life in this
is fine fine yeah I think effect even
Christian Rockies is that everything
electronic in the whole house is off
what we do now well I guess we could
talk to each other this isn't talking
this is singing
I told you
okay what about the war in Iraq I
personally think it means
oh that was just far the song I have no
interested me at all sorry don't uh fuck
off all right the show is freaking me
out how about we take a look at
something that isn't the least bit scary
are you afraid of it I'm not
particularly frightening are you afraid
of the dark was well not particularly
Frank I guess he was trying to be like a
kid-friendly version of Tales from the
Crypt but even then the only scary part
about that what's a Crypt Keeper can
hunt I've heard of giving someone
ridiculous ah it was about a group of
kids that will mean only night to tell
quote-unquote scary stories and every
single one would have different
characters had different set up so
somehow they always managed to have the
same storyline have you ever noticed
that there's always one kid who's kind
and innocent and other kid who's always
a pain in the ass the pain in the ass
always gets his or her come up and from
something supernatural a lot of good kid
always saves the day as they both learn
a valuable lesson and ultimately results
in a happy ending now while I have to
admit being taught alyssa from a TV show
can be very scary at that age they show
wasn't the least bit frightening one of
the biggest problems is the actors on
the show sometimes you would get a good
child actor but for the most part they
were very rare among the mix my favorite
is this one care from the tail of the
phantom camera like watch this kids
stellar change of emotion cool I'm
playing to emotions at once
a shame he can't get you know the right
cool or how about this scene where he
tries to figure out a riddle this old
wizard gave what you can't see
or can you
wait a second there's a trick here can't
put something in the barrel to make a
lighter you have to take something out
if you take something out of the barrel
itself it'll be lighter that's pretty
bad actually inside thing sounds a
little familiar it's gonna get us both
killed
it's like they had the same acting coach
however the most annoying part is just
the kids who are telling the story who
call themselves the midnight society I
think these kids take this stuff way too
seriously
we called the midnight society where my
next to the dungeon the Dragons
role-playing game separately we're very
different we like different things we go
to different schools and we have
different friends Salle's life was in
gender Phenom II but one thing chose us
together smoking we eat around the
fireplace the dark and smoking weed
around the fireplace this is a warning
to all join us you're going to leave the
comfortable light and step into the
world of the supernatural
we play Magic the Gathering bitches
what okay what's with the blindfold yeah
what's with the blindfold this meeting
place is secret yeah and you're not in
yet there are people who would kill
their unborn babies to find this
location through sponsors Frank
we have sponsors I do he's a good guy
yeah but can you tell a good story who
said that who can question my
storytelling abilities not so the person
tells the story and at the end they have
a vote as to whether or not he should be
allowed in this most sacred of bullshit
societies and now the vote thumbs up
means franksen thumbs down he's not and
it has to be anonymous hey um it's not
really necessary I mean couldn't we just
say whether or not we like the story I
mean I go a lot faster you don't
understand the rules of this society
without these rules this whole
organization would fall apart yeah about
that - um do we really have to be so
official all the time I mean can't we
just
I don't know eat some snacks drink some
beer maybe tell a story you know do
stuff my kids are supposed to do I don't
think you're a team player anymore kid
do I have to unleash the rabid crotch
fighting little beasts again just go go
when we said thank good so like I said
thumbs up Kiki
Betty Ann Kristin Eric Sian
dreadful I also like the fact that
before every story that throw magic dust
on the fire that somehow makes the title
appear I guess it's just magic credit
dust or something actually I always
thought that stuff was cocaine and
that's why the kids kept coming back all
the time but I will give it this it was
at least entertaining
I mean Sheree was can't be but a lot of
it was created and did often keep my
interest until the end of the show so I
guess that's something and I guess for
really really young kids it was a decent
enough show but enough of all bad let's
move on to all that all that meaning all
that that entails but all that the TV
series that was in fact all that bag of
chips but all that you know already
because all of that alright this joke is
dead as if Nick didn't have enough
sketch show we were given all that very
hit and miss comedy that actually had a
cast that was half African America and I
gotta admit that was pretty damn cool
but in living color had mostly
african-american races though it is
funny because when you look at the show
about ten years later Wow look how white
and up it became it's like a plain black
coffee turning into a lattes and just
giving up and turning into milk pump it
like the least sickening hello well we
were there at the start with the
original characters and sketches like
the two old guys you look like Don King
and Uncle Remus excuse me guys could you
keep it down a little bit
clay with the girl what that man said
that you must be the president of the
audience or the good burger kid who's he
to encompass all the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles at just one voice welcome
to good burger home of the good burger
can I take your order or how about
cheese police the foreign guy or ear boy
all right some of these characters
didn't seem like Sam tires of sand tires
but and they weren't all like that some
of them were pretty good like I love the
librarian who would always try to keep
peace and quiet in the library by
yelling at the top of her lungs
that's funny enough but then she
proceeds to yell on the phone eat chips
play the drums and even do some
construction work that's actually pretty
funny I also like learning French with
Pierre where he taught you phrases that
made you sound like you have no idea how
to speak French je vous voulez vous voir
la pizza plus you have to give them
credit on the best Ross Perot impression
ever done in the history of comedy
performed my little girl with rubber
gears right on the cookie prosthetic
nose
so good snuff
Wow right down to the fact that he
thinks he actually has money how
delightfully perceptive and speaking of
impressions he's a weird little
coincidence Kenan Thompson who would go
on to do Bill Cosby on Saturday Night
Live is actually doing Bill Cosby here
is a little kid then you go grab a
permanent mark God and proceeded to run
her name on the forehead he grew into it
now like I said this show was hit and
miss so there was certainly a lot of
sketches that weren't that funny to like
I never thought the vital information
sketch was money but obviously the
writers thought it was because they used
it all the friggin time if you're
standing in a line it's rude to keep
turning to the person behind you and
saying I in front of you I'm doing right
of you here's another one
when writing is sched don't assume that
things are funny because you scream it
because it's not a little miss muffet
sits on your tuffet say hey Miss Muffet
get your butt off my tuffet
can you believe those silly writers
thinking something is funny simply
because your screen it screaming and
every other sentence is not funny it is
loud and annoying and anyone who does it
should be shot I'm shot give it a bag of
money how about some lounge music yeah
some sketches were stupid but we still
found it funny like how about the old
man who would scream out the window just
telling things to shops ghostwritten
stop it you farted Birds I'm gonna
masturbate and then out of nowhere
whatever he was yelling yet was suddenly
attack that's so stupid but for some
reason it always made me well a lot of
the show was like that for all its
problems all that certainly knew how to
keep us entertained and always keep us
coming back now it's time for watching
sniff around this point but there's two
other shows I got talking about simply
because everybody says I gotta talk
about one of the shows was complain kind
of like a cartoon sketch show they used
a variety of different animation now the
problem is I couldn't really find any
full episodes all I can find is a series
of sketches called action League which
kind of looks like my GI Joes beating up
some Barbies and another series of
sketches called Prometheus and Bob which
is about an alien who trying to teach a
caveman how to evolve but the caveman
never catches on both of these sketches
are funny I guess but like I said I
couldn't find anything else so that's
about all I can really talk about the
other show is called Kenan & Kel based
off of the two most popular actors off
of all that but what I can tell it about
is that Coolio
hello fuck did I get called nothing
seriously this is the guy who said
gangsta's paradise was too serious to be
parodied and he's doing the opening my
kid show how the hell does that work
yeah well you know I was hesitant at
first but then I started watching the
show all that and I thought these boys
really knew what it's like to suffer
because lord knows I suffered through a
lot of them good burger sketches and
they would all about paint boy they know
all about represent so I took a look at
a special TV movie they made called two
heads are better than hug which is about
Keenan's family going on vacation as his
best friend Cal tags along and from what
I could gather it wasn't that bad it was
kind of hip missing all that though like
when they want to sit around the
campfire and tell ghost stories win the
bread
popped out of the toaster no one knew
what to put on it he said let tell ghost
stories
not ghost stories hey boss there's no
midnight society involved I don't care
what shitty jokes they tell the comedy
is pretty customary Keenan is the
cynical smart one while kill is the
energetic dumb yeah I haven't seen that
before 11 battles of order on the wall
well that's it go stop on the left
you mean we have to stick to a million
bottles of ours not on the wall you so
stop at 11 you're not even finish yeah
I'm tired of that song I fire also what
is awkward Keenan's heroness he wants
another black Cabbage Patch Kids what
was that just the style then oh look the
fire's dying down maybe I should go get
some more wood for it
actually keen starting to sound a little
familiar to me too naked and I didn't
want to get to my word
what cuz its flaming deaf and everybody
said naked year the Keeney continued
everybody's under day care be weary for
Kenny shit where did the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
well even though wasn't really anything
new I guess keeping Intel was heartless
enough I mean where else can you see
people dancing to a Ludacris song being
performed by a piano playing monkey well
ok that what episode of you but I don't
think I can so that's about all I gotta
say about stick
it was fun goofy and an enjoyable way to
spend your Saturday night before you
discovered booze and how to break the
law so yeah it couldn't be more detailed
but most of the shows every went over in
the last two episodes and everything
else I was too old for but hey next week
we're gonna be tackling my favorite
Nickelodeon subject Nickelodeon game
shows that's right we're gonna be going
over all your favorites like guts oh we
couldn't find any good videos for guts
well okay we'll be going over other
shows like wild and crazy kids
oh no good quality videos for that
either
okay well what game shows do me it don't
air that's it
I already did double dare you miserable
pile of blues I can't do it again
great so I have no high quality videos
too
do the Nickelodeon game shows with
that's just wonderful how am i both end
McGlone a month hmm I can't just stop in
the middle come on give me something
anything I'll take the worst thing that
Nickelodeon has ever produced
the absolute worst I don't care how bad
horrible terrifying thing that including
has never
on beach
as I can take
so tell me what exactly
ah